[Music]
okay we're going to interrupt our
regular programming to bring you some
breaking news coming out of the United
Kingdom Britain's Queen Elizabeth II is
currently we're here under medical
supervision at her residence in Balmoral
in Scotland we're just getting that news
it's coming in on the wires for us
doctors are saying they are concerned
about her health now we've heard in the
past few minutes from the speaker of
parliament Lindsay Hoyle this is what he
had to say let's have a listen to
exactly what he said I wish there's
something about the announcement which
has just been made about her majesty
I know I speak on behalf of the entire
house when I said that we send our best
wishes to a Magister the queen and that
she and the royal family are in our
thoughts and prayers at this moment I'm
going to take no more just to if there
is anything else we will look at the
house accordingly thank you in Blackford
thank you Mr Speaker and I'm sure on
behalf of all colleagues that were
saddened to hear the announcement that's
been made okay so clearly uh this
information uh just coming out now it's
all uh new information coming out of the
United Kingdom what we know is that the
queen is under medical supervision at
Balmoral after doctors became concerned
for her health this is according to a
statement from Buckingham Palace uh I'm
just going to go over some of that
statement this is what it says following
further evaluation this morning the
Queen's doctors are concerned for Her
Majesty's health and have recommended
she remain under medical supervision
this is a statement coming in from
Buckingham Palace the queen remains
comfortable
and she is at Balmoral now we've also
starting to get reaction coming in from
various parts of the country including
Liz truss the new prime minister
of the UK this is what she had to say in
the last 20 minutes or so
that the whole country this is prime
minister Liz trust saying that the whole
country is deeply concerned by the news
she says my thoughts and the thoughts of
people across our United Kingdom are
with her majesty the queen and her
family at this time now in case you're
just joining us just to clarify the news
coming in to us is that the queen is
currently under medical supervision at
Balmoral her residence in Scotland this
happened after doctors became concerned
for her health that is according to a
statement that has been officially
released by Buckingham Palace now the
queen uh
uh 96 years old
now we know that uh
she pulled she pulled out a virtual
privy Council on Wednesday with doctors
advising her to rest we are now hearing
that Prince Charles and Camilla are
traveling they're all currently
traveling to Balmoral to be with the
queen we don't know at what point they
were informed they were staying nearby
apparently at Burke Hall on the estate
so perhaps they are already with the
queen so just to repeat that Prince
Charles and Camilla traveling to
Balmoral we're also getting news that
Prince William is also on his way to
Balmoral this is the Queen's residence
in Scotland and this is
he's decided to travel there after this
news this announcement on the Queen's
Health that is what we are hearing uh we
can go to our correspondent worry
challenge who is in London
Rory uh what what else are you hearing
about this this is uh coming to us all
by surprise
yeah this is breaking news I mean I
think the things that you have just been
outlining there we've got messages from
the Prime Minister we have uh messages
of concern for the Queen's Health coming
from her doctors we know that the
immediate family have been informed and
are now coming to be with her these are
all the kinds of things that you would
expect to happen if the queen did not
have uh very long to live all these
things being put in place to make sure
that if she does die in the coming days
that her family are there and that the
country is prepared for it that the
government is prepared for it as well I
mean you have to remember that just it
was a couple of days ago that Liz truss
went up to Balmoral uh to be basically
appointed as the Prime Minister that is
something that usually happens down in
London it usually happens at Buckingham
Palace that the new prime minister will
go to the queen at Buckingham Palace and
be appointed there but the queen was not
well enough to travel down south from
where she had been in Scotland and so
Liz truss had to make her way up there
for that ceremony
so that gives us a sense uh really that
this queen uh 96 years old as we know is
in frail condition at the moment and has
been for some time she's had difficulty
walking uh difficulty with her Mobility
her husband's died last year Prince
Philip and for the last year at least
the queen has really scaled back on the
number of appointments and
ceremonies and official duties that she
has been performing really keeping quite
a low profile we did see photographs of
her with Liz truss a couple of days ago
as you say there was a privy council
meeting that she was supposed to be
taking yesterday on Wednesday that was
canceled so growing concerns I think for
the Queen's health and and as I just
said the kinds of things that are being
put in place now the kind of things that
are happening are all the the sorts of
things you would expect to happen if the
queen was perhaps in her final days you
were referring to that meeting between
Liz trust and the queen which took place
a few days ago now we're actually
looking at that picture she does look uh
frail but she is standing up uh and as
you say it was a break-in tradition that
uh that she met with Liz trust and the
outgoing prime minister Boris Johnson in
Balmoral in Scotland rather in London
which is what traditionally she she
would have done or has done in the past
and we were told at the time that was
because she suffered from mobility
issues uh
she also had a meeting I believe an
online meeting on Wednesday with the
privy Council which then she canceled
after being advised to rest by doctors I
mean talk us through some of the sort of
the latest health issues that as she is
96 years old but she has she has
increasingly sort of been stepping out
of public life hasn't she
um
yeah she has uh so the Queen's Health
has has clearly been on a downward
trajectory for for some time as you
would expect for someone of her
significant age he is an old woman she
is the longest serving uh British
monarch uh by a reasonable margin now
and she has been on the throne
performing her duties for since 1952
1953 she is uh you know a venerable
woman who's been doing what she's done
many stories of her being in and out of
hospital for conditions of this and that
and uh
most of those she has come out of and
has then bounced back into performing
some duties not all of the ones that she
was performing when she was a healthier
woman a younger woman but certainly kept
up her duties in recent months that has
really uh been pulled back and and the
number of things that the queen has been
obliged to leave the Comforts of her
official residences for has been you
know a handful at most so you know you
can see that this is a woman of
declining abilities uh a declining
Health but we now get the impression uh
that this is taking a significantly
worse turn and perhaps I think we should
be prepared for another announcement to
come not necessarily imminently but for
something to happen in the next few days
and of course then the country goes into
a a whole different uh mode of of the
official mourning all that kind of thing
prime minister Liz truss who is has just
come into office is dealing with a an
energy crisis we heard from her earlier
on today talking about capping price
builds she will have to I think switch
gears very very fast uh if we do get
that news from from Buckingham Palace
she will have to then become a prime
minister in mourning